welcome everyone this is Rob Sanders and
today we're gonna talk about Google tag
manager thanks for joining and let's get
started with this simply learn webinar
so let's start out with why GTM so let's
just say you're Sam and you have your
own e-commerce website you want to
understand how people are interacting
with your website well Sam today's world
of websites contain a lot of
interactivity everything from videos to
PDF downloads to commenting to form
submissions to all sorts of chat
functionality interactivity going on
throughout the website so there's just a
lot that you need to track outside of
just pageviews and so really what GTM
does is they help you track all these
things I just mentioned everything from
somebody clicking on the play button of
a PDF to somebody clicking on the submit
button of a form to somebody entering in
something on a chat function so that's
what GTM is so why GTM because it helps
us track all that interactivity so all
GTM is is really allows you to really
place a piece of java code which is just
script and the script that's added to a
web page to collect information so
that's really what a tag is it's just
some script that gets put on a web page
an order for you to collect information
like page views clicks etc and they send
it to third-party tools ok so that's
what GTM does it basically allows you to
take all these tags that collect
information and you can use them in gta
so if you want to for example collect
how many people you know enter a chat
functionality and start chatting well
you're going to take that script and
you're going to put it in GTM and GTM
will then allow you to start tracking
that information
so that's really what UTM is it just
allows you to put tags into a container
or
think of it as a toy box you have all
these toys and you want to track well
you can put all those those toys or tags
in a toy box or container we're gonna
talk a little bit more about that but
before we get into GTM let's just say
you know you're communicating with your
developer and there's a new user request
on your webpage and you want to update
the tag well your developer consider and
it's probably a small update your
website is probably gonna not hesitate
and is gonna go ahead and turn around
and do it normally and so normally what
happens is the developer is gonna go to
the website and update the tag well what
if you have a few things that you want
to track all these things I mentioned
before from downloads - clicks - you
know somebody checking out - watching a
video well your webmaster your web
developer is gonna go well hold on a
second now all these requests are gonna
take time I need to put them into the
work queue so to speak well what happens
is when they go into work you usually
it's going to take some time and in some
cases you as a marketer need to launch a
campaign and you want to get that
tracking added to the website in time
for the campaign launch so you want to
go ahead and quickly turnaround the
tracking for that particular campaign
let's just say you're launching a
campaign and you're sending people to a
landing page that has a form submission
and you want to be able to track how
many people click on the submit button
and that form submission well if you
need to turn that around your developers
like well I need to put that in the work
queue the time it isn't going to always
work out between you and your developer
is my point and so that's where GTM
comes in because there is a solution
update your tags faster and that's
Google tag manager so when we say GTM
that's what GTM stands for a Google tag
manager someplace for you to add tags
quickly and easily so tags remember are
just snippets a code that allow you to
track things on your website
interactivity interactive activity and
basically when you have GTM you can
bypass the webmaster and do it quickly
and easily so that's what
all about so why GTM because we just
identified two benefits one you could
track all the interactivity on your
website and two you can bypass your web
developer or webmaster and so that's the
benefit of GTM so the benefit you get
those tags updated very quickly via
Google tag manager okay so that's what
tag manager is so what we're going to
talk about today is specifically what
tag manager is and what it does we're
gonna list some of the benefits of tag
manager we're gonna show you how it
works and then we're gonna show you how
to get started with tag manager tag
manager if you're not familiar with
working with webmasters and dealing with
JavaScript and tags and all this jargon
is just new to you today okay well don't
fret sit back we're gonna take it slow
this is an introduction into Google tag
manager again let's start out with what
is tag manager so we've already
introduced it to some degree because we
already introduced is a tool where you
can put all your tags into a toolbox toy
box or container so to speak right and
we already already mentioned that hey
you can bypass your webmaster so you're
probably thinking well if I'm if you're
not familiar with tag manager how can i
bypass my webmaster well first of all
it's a free tool and it's a Google tool
hence the name Google tag manager and it
helps you really that's the main point
it's deploying track tags on your
website bypassing your webmaster so
that's kayak manager and so examples of
tags that can be deployed vehicle the
tag manager are numerous these are just
some examples like Google Analytics
Facebook pixel tracking or Google Ads
there's no limit into the number of tags
you can track and tag manager there is
no limit you can add any number of
tracking tags and tag manager okay so
some of the benefits
well again I we just listed two you can
put any tag into tag manager and track
that onto your website and we know you
can bypass your web developer or
webmaster and what it also does is it
also allows you to test and deploy your
JavaScript code
quicker so remember these JavaScript
codes or snippets of codes are just
there to track certain things on your
website whether that be a page view or
somebody clicking on a play button or
tracking somebody who converts or even
just goes to your website so the biggest
benefit is you can take that snippet of
code let's just say Facebook let's just
say you're doing Facebook marketing and
you want to put that Facebook pixel on
your website so that you could track
people who come from Facebook and
convert well you don't need to put that
Facebook pixel on your website you can
go right to tag manager and you can put
that snippet of code right in tag
manager really quickly and the other
benefit here is all tags are managed in
one place and that's that to me is
really a good benefit because when you
start adding tags on your website and
you have some tags and tag manager it
just gets very confusing so ideally all
the tracking codes you have on your
website needs to be intact manager think
about that all the tracking so if you're
doing Bing or you're doing Facebook
you're doing Twitter are you doing
LinkedIn and you're doing Google you're
doing all this type of marketing on all
these different platforms you're gonna
have tracking code for all these
different platforms and instead of
putting on that code on your website
return gonna slow down the slow time of
your webpage and website you want to put
them all in tag manager so they can be
organized and you know exactly what
you're trying to track and the other
great benefit of tag manager is there's
a versioning control so let's just say
you have added tags to your website via
GTM for the last six months well let's
just say you add another tag yesterday
if you added that tag yesterday and
something doesn't work well you can just
roll back to a previous version it's
that simple so you have versioning and
that's that's a good thing when you have
versioning you could control what gets
published and if something doesn't work
after it gets published then you can
roll back to a previous version so it's
a peace of mind so to speak just because
you've add Coach to your site there's no
guarantee it's gonna work and so you can
always control what version you're
dealing with and tag manager and we'll
talk a little bit more about that so the
biggest benefit here to me with tag
manager
is you have a vent tracking and so we
talked about some of the things you
could track on your website from videos
from play buttons to somebody clicking
on the stop on the video or pausing it
all the way to somebody again chatting
or let's just say somebody clicking on
that purchase button on your website
okay and you want to track all these
different things these different
interactivities and buttons
well event tracking is what you're going
to use to track all those buttons and to
me this is the biggest benefit of tag
manager and I'll show you some examples
as we go along and if we didn't mention
it already I'll mention it again it is
free tag manager is free there's no
limit so once you have tag manager going
you can add as many tracking codes as
you want there's no limit on the number
of tracking codes you can add to tag
manager ok so it's free and you can use
it to its fullest advantage ok so it's
also high security meaning that it has
different levels of permissions ok so
you can have somebody just go in and
look at the different tags and tracking
code you have in GTM or you can ask
somebody who is very familiar with tag
manager you can go in and add the
tracking code to tag manager and then
publish that tracking code when it gets
at it so those are all the benefits
let's talk about how it works now
specifically how does tag manager work
cuz you're like Rob okay again a lot of
jargon you know you got tags and drive a
script and in versioning and publishing
and all this other stuff well I know I'm
throwing a lot at you at once but just
bear with me here ok so let's start
talking about how it actually works so
you have a website okay whatever that
domain is you have a website and there's
chances are on your website you have
some form of interactive
whether that be a video whether that be
a blog whether it be a form submission
you have a website with some
interactivity and let's just say you're
even thinking about getting ready to
launch some type of campaign on maybe
Google or Facebook and you want to drive
traffic to your website fair enough
you're joining the millions of other
websites that are out there that have
interactivity that also drive traffic to
the website so in comes Google tag
manager and so tag manager is important
because again we know we want to track
people coming from that Facebook
campaign or that Google campaign and
interacting with our site so if you are
running Facebook and you are running
Google Analytics well guess what you
want to put that tracking code in tag
manager so Google Analytics being a
Google product works very nicely with
tag manager Facebook has its own
tracking code but you still want to be
able to track people who come from the
Facebook campaign to your website so
you're gonna get that tracking code from
Facebook and put it in tag manager
that's generally how it works
so here information from your website is
shared with another data source through
tag manager so think about that if I add
Facebook tracking code to tag manager or
let's just say a Google Analytics
tracking code
- tag manager tag manager is the one
that's pushing out and doing all the
heavy lifting
they're the ones that are controlling
what code gets fired and what code
doesn't so if you're putting the code in
tag matters tag manager is controlling
the code think about it that way
and let's show you an example of what
that looks like so here I am I'm in tag
manager I just went to tag manager
google.com and here I could see a list
of tags so in our conversation we're
talking about tracking Facebook and
we're talking about tracking Google
Analytics well Google Analytics is easy
because it's a Google product so here if
I look at all the different tracking
code I have on my website through tag
manager let's just take a look at Google
Analytics so if you're gonna use tag
manager you might as well put the Google
Analytics code in here so here I can see
I have Google Analytics as a tag in
tag manager now for Facebook if I'm
running a Facebook campaign well I can
take that pixel tracking and put it in
GTM as well and here I could see
Facebook pixel
that is that code is added to GTM I just
basically took what Facebook gave me and
put it in a Google tag manager so you
can see I can add Facebook and Google
Analytics and again I can't stress it
enough any tracking code from any
platform I can add to Google tag manager
in order to track the behavior from
those sources so let's take a little bit
deeper dive into how tag manager works
so I just showed you an example of how
you could take Facebook and Google
Analytics code and put it in a tag
manager but if you're not familiar with
tag manager then how do I do that well
let's talk about the structure and how
tag manager works so when you have a tag
manager account you have a container
remember I mentioned toybox
earlier you have a bunch of toys if
they're their code and you're tracking
different bits of code from different
platforms like Facebook think of those
as toys and you have a toy box okay well
that's what this code is and that's what
a container is the code is the code and
that's gonna go into the toy box or
container and so the weight tag manager
works is you have tags triggers and
variables so if I take my Facebook
tracking code and put it into a
container I need to set up a tag and a
trigger okay so let's take a look at
what that is so first if I go back to
tag manager I'm gonna have an account
and if I have an account I'm going to
have a container so here I'm just gonna
click on an account with a container and
a container is nothing more than what
website you're adding the tracking code
to okay that's all the container is
we're just letting tag manager know this
is the website we're adding all this
code to so you have tags triggers and
variables that's the structure of tag
manager so tags are just what it says
tags what are we trying to quote unquote
tag well if it's Google Analytics that's
easy here I could
see I've Google Analytics at it so if I
click on Google Analytics here's my tag
and if I take a little bit of a deeper
dive there since Google Analytics is a
Google product it integrates already
with tag managers it's pretty easy I can
just choose Google Analytics then I'm
gonna check page view and that's my tag
now every tag needs a trigger okay so I
need to tell tag manager how or when to
fire the Google Analytics tracking code
so in this case I'm gonna tell tag
manager to fire on all pages so if I get
somebody a visitor to my website
analytics is firing on all pages so
whatever page that visitor lands on
Google Analytics is gonna fire so that's
really what it comes down to is I have a
tag and I need to tell tag manager when
to trigger that tag that's really what
the structure of tag manager is it's
tags triggers and variables and
variables we're gonna talk about here in
a couple minutes but you have a piece of
code you're gonna go ahead and put that
into tag manager
you're gonna tag it and then you're
going to fire that trigger so let's take
a look at another example here if I go
back here you can see Facebook well
here's my Facebook pixel okay that's my
tag so when is it gonna fire well it's
gonna fire on a specific domain or sub
domain that's basically what we're doing
we're trying to tell GTM when to fire
that particular tag so those are the
three main components a tag okay which
is going to contain the JavaScript code
that you get from safe Facebook the
trigger so you're going to go into tag
manager and tell tag manager when to
fire that code that's the trigger and
then you have variables and so variables
are basically just additional
information that tag manager may need
for your tag and trigger to work so
that's what a variable is it's there to
get the tag and trigger to fire so
variables are divided into built in and
user defined variables so common use
variables
includ say page path or page URL or
hostname or click class again they're
there and these examples I just gave you
are there to get your tag and trigger to
work think about it that way they're
just that's a component and if I go into
tag manager here and here on the left
side I can see variables so remember I
have built-in and user-defined so
built-in means that tag manager already
built these for me so in case I need to
get my trigger to work with my tag I can
use a variable so those are built in and
then I have user-defined so these are
what I define these are what I created
and again the variables are there to get
the tag and trigger to work ok so that's
the job of the variable the job of the
tag is to host that JavaScript code ok
in the case of Facebook or analytics
that's where we're putting our code so
here if I click on AdWords remarketing
again it's a Google product so I don't
really need to even deal with code I'm
just gonna select Google AdWords for
marketing ok so you can see GTM
integrates nicely with some of the other
Google products but let's just say you
have a Facebook pixel tracking code
you're gonna choose custom and you're
gonna put the code here so that's part
of the tag and then the trigger again is
there to get the tag to fire so you're
telling GTM when to fire the tag and the
variable is there to help you make sure
that that trigger and that tag work
together so that's how all three kind of
work together you need the tag to put
the code you need the trigger to tell G
team when to fire the tag and code and
the variables there to help you define
when that tag and trigger should work or
how it should work so again a review
tags are they're just small codes a
JavaScript or tracking pixels on your
website and so tags are allowed to
manage events like scroll track and
remarketing clicks downloads files play
buttons you name it even clicks on
external links for example let's just
say you have a click or a Facebook icon
on your site and when some
clicks on it they go to Facebook you
want to maybe track that you're gonna
create a tag and the trigger is there
because you need to tell GTM when to
fire that tag so it's a certain
condition whether it's you know fire the
tag if the URL equals facebook.com or
some other condition so the tag cannot
be created until the creation of the
corresponding trigger so tags and
triggers go together you can't just
create a tag and not have a trigger
otherwise your tag will never fire and
then the variable was there again it
stores the information when defining a
trigger or transferring data as a tag so
a variable has a variety of data okay so
you pick and choose the variable you
want to use with that trigger okay so
you're making sure that by defining a
variable you're making sure that you're
telling GTM how that trigger should be
fired so let's take a look at another
example here of how all three play
together if I'm in this account I'm in
this container if I look down here I
could see google optimize that's another
Google product so what I'm doing here is
I just chose google optimize as my tag
it's already integrated so what does
that mean I don't even need to deal with
any code I'm just gonna select optimize
well we have the tag Google optimize but
we need to tell GTM how to fire that and
so here we're going to tell GT on the
fired on all pages so that's basically a
very simple example because we're firing
it on all pages so if I want to look at
something specific again Facebook here's
my tag here's my code what's my trigger
well my trigger is it's gonna fire on
specific pages how do I know that well
if I look at the trigger here I can see
the trigger is a page view but I'm
telling it to fire on this particular
hostname so the tag and trigger go hand
in hand
you
so how to get started with tag manager
so first things first you have to create
that account so you're going to go to
tag manager google comm or you can do a
search for Google tag manager and you're
going to create your account and then
when you create your account what's
gonna happen is you're going to set up a
container and when you set up a
container you have choices so you could
set it up for your website for an app on
iOS or maybe Android or you can even set
it up for a MPX at an accelerated and
mobile page so most people by default
are probably going to set up tag manager
for their website and so when you do
that when you actually select website
what's going to happen is you're going
to get some Google tag manager code in
return and so the whole idea here is
you're going to do a swap what you're
doing is basically you're saying okay
Google I'm gonna take this Google tag
manager code and I'm gonna put it on my
website I'm gonna put it on every page
of my website
so notice tag manager has two scripts
one goes in the head as high as possible
the other goes into the body tag as high
as possible and so what you're doing is
you're making a deal you're putting this
tag manager code on your website and
then return every code you deal with
whether that be Facebook or analytics or
optimized or remarketing or whatever it
is is gonna go in GTM okay it's gonna go
into the container you created so you
need the tag manager code on your
website in order for tag manager to work
okay so when you add this code to your
website then you're free to start adding
all sorts of tags to your container but
if you don't have this tracking code on
your website then none of the tags you
add to your container are gonna work so
that's the idea behind the container and
then one thing I wanted to mention on
the
count is it's a Google account so when
you create your account then make sure
it's the same account you use with say
Google Analytics or some other Google
product that's a good best practice as
always use the same email address when
you set up your account so that it
integrates nicely across all the
different platforms meaning you can go
from say Google Analytics right to
Google tag manager and one browser
without having a log out or log in okay
so when you create the account you're
gonna create your container if you
choose web then you're gonna be asked to
place code on your website and when you
place that code on your website then you
are free to start using tag manager and
that means you're free to start adding
tags and so if you want to know more
information about installing Google tag
manager then what I would recommend is
visit the Quick Start Guide website of
GTM so again if you're curious as to
where that code is located in Google tag
manager well when you create an account
and you create in container that
container is gonna have a specific ID so
if I click on that specific ID here's
where I can get my code ok so again when
I'm logged in to tag manager I'm gonna
click on workspace but in the top
navigation I'm gonna see my unique GTM
ID if I click on that that's where my
code is gonna be located and so again
your code needs to go in the header and
there's another script that needs to go
in the body and if you're not sure how
to add the code to your website well you
can always click on the QuickStart guide
here ok and that will take you to a
QuickStart guide page a reference page
related to Google tag manager so let's
talk about creating a tag so once you
get tag manager installed I'm sure
you're excited to get going and create
that first tag so let's talk about how
to create a tag in tag manager so when
you're in tag manager all you need to do
is basically you're looking at all your
tags if you click on tag in the
left-side navigation you'll see all your
tags and there's a new button there so
you just click new and so basically what
you're
do is you're going to create your first
tag and so what I would recommend once
you get tag manager installed on your
website I would recommend setting the
first tag up as Google Analytics so that
will get you going with tracking page
views on your website when someone
somebody visits your website okay so
ideally that's what you want to do you
want to get Google Analytics as your
first tag and tag manager so what I'm
going to do is because analytics is a
Google product it's already integrated
nicely with tag manager so I'm just
gonna click on Google Analytics it's
going to be a page view that's what I'm
tracking and now I have to set up a
variable and so what it's going to do
it's gonna ask me to sort of select a
variable and so what you're gonna do is
you're gonna select new variable and
what you're going to do is you're
actually gonna go and add your tracking
ID here that's gonna be your variable so
where do I get my tracking ID and
analytics well if I'm in analytics I'm
gonna go to admin and in under property
settings I'm gonna see my tracking ID
and all you need to do then is go to tag
manager and paste copy first you get a
copy over that tracking ID then you're
going to get a tag manager and paste it
and then that's going to create a
variable for you and then when you
create that variable you're gonna see it
in the drop down here so I've already
created it and basically that's your tag
with a variable then what are you gonna
do you're gonna set up a trigger so see
I'll have some triggers already set up
you're gonna see a default trigger
already set up for you and then it's
gonna be all pages so ideally what you
want to do is you want to select all
pages in order for analytics to fire on
all pages so that's what we're doing
we're setting up a trigger we're
basically telling tag manager hey if I
get a visitor to any page on my website
then I want you to fire Google Analytics
so that's basically in summary how to
set up your first tag and my
recommendation is your first tag should
be Google Analytics and when you set up
analytics you're gonna have to set up a
variable for the tracking ID
and so you get the tracking ID again
from admin property settings copy and
paste that tracking ID over save it
you have your variable that variable is
going to be included in with the tag and
your trigger is gonna be all pages and
there you go you have your first tag you
have your first variable you have your
first trigger so that's basically what
you want to do and once you've added
that tag once you've added that trigger
then the only thing you need to do now
is basically publish the tag and so
anytime you save a tag you're going to
go ahead and some minutes so that way it
gets published so again what you're
gonna do is let's take a step back here
you're going to choose new tag you're
going to choose analytics from the drop
down menu you're gonna choose page view
then basically you're going to add your
tracking ID so you could set up the
variable and then basically that's what
you need to do okay you're gonna add
that tracking ID and then voila that's
your tag with a variable and then once
you've done that then you're going to
click Submit
so when you click Submit you're
basically saying hey I want this tag to
go live now this tagging trigger and
once you've done that then analytics is
ready to go and anytime somebody goes to
your website on any page tag managers
gonna fire Google Analytics so the great
thing here is you have something called
Google tag assistant and that's a an
extension that works with Chrome and so
when you've actually add a tag manager
to your site or you have analytics
running and tag manager you can confirm
if those tags are firing properly so
let's take a look at how Google tag
assistant works okay so if you just do a
search for Google tag assistant you're
gonna see here that it's basically just
an extension that works in chrome and it
unfortunately it only works in Chrome
browser it doesn't work in any other
browser so go ahead and install that
extension into Chrome and when you do
that you're gonna see this nice icon
here in your browser and now if you go
to any website and I click on
Google tag assistant and I click on
enable ok so basically I'm loading
Google tag assistant and now once i
refresh the page I can see that this
particular site has Google tag manager
installed and not only does it have tag
manager installed I can see that it's
also has Google Analytics running
I have also Google optimized running and
I have Google ads remarketing tag
running in tag manager so that's what
tag assistant does it allows you to see
if one tag manager is on the site and if
it is great what other tags are firing
on this particular site so tag
assistants telling me I have these
particular tags firing on that site and
they're firing within tag manager so tag
assistant is a great way to confirm if
one tag manager is on the site and to
what other tags are firing on the site
now another way you could confirm if tag
manager is firing on the site is you can
go in a preview mode so even before you
submit and publish your tag and trigger
you can click on the preview mode so if
I click preview in tag manager so
basically that's going to put me in
preview mode and so what does that mean
well that means that now I'm free to go
to my website and see if those tags are
firing and so let's take a look at what
that looks like so if I go to the
website and just click refresh then
what's going to happen is tag manager is
gonna load in preview mode just as you
see here ok so that's gonna take a
second couple seconds to load up and now
what can I see in preview mode I could
see that I have GTM firing but I also
have some other tax firing on this page
remarketing I have Google Analytics by
Google optimized I have some other tags
firing as well and so the preview mode
shows me what tags are firing on any
given page and I can also see what tags
did not fire ok so here I have a number
of tags already in GTM but they didn't
fire on this particular page so let's
just say I clicked on the doe
now button I'm still in preview mode so
I'm gonna be able to see what tags fire
now I can see I have a couple of tags
that I've fired on this particular page
and then I can see what tags did not
fire on this page okay so that's the pre
me mode you can use the preview mode
before you even submit a tag and trigger
to see if it fires and that's the great
benefit of tag manager so if you're not
sure if something's going to fire or not
then you can always go into preview mode
and if you are sure it's gonna fire then
you can go ahead and submit it so you
can leave preemie mode and just go ahead
and submit that particular tag and
trigger so here I'm going to leave
preview mode and now once I'm done and
I'm sure the tag is gonna fire and go
ahead and submit all my changes that
I've worked on in terms of setting up
tags and triggers so that's really GTM
in a nutshell so I have my tags okay my
tags are just snippets of code that I'm
going to put in whether that be face
book or vet tracking or any other Google
products like optimize or page view then
I have my triggers my triggers are there
to tell GTM when to fire that tag and
the variables are there to help those
tags and triggers work together so
remember that particular variable we set
up for Google Analytics okay so here it
is right here because we want to tell
GTM what property to specifically fire
in Google Analytics so that's why we set
up that variable but there are all sorts
of variables Google tag manager has
built in more variables already created
for you or you can specifically define a
variable so variables are there to help
the tags and triggers work together so
when you set up a tag you set up a
trigger you use a variable you can
always go into preview mode preview it
by going to the website seeing if it
fires if it fires then voila
you can go ahead
and click Submit and that will publish
the tag and trigger and you're good to
go
that's pretty much how tag manager works
and again I can't stress that there's an
unlimited number of tags you can add to
tag manager there's no limit so you got
everything from anything from google
tuned on google to event tracking ok to
Facebook to anything that you want to
track you want to be able to put into
tag manager and again there's versioning
that's one of the great benefits of tag
manager so if I want to go back to an
older version I can simply do that so
here you can see I'm on version 32
that's how tag manager works and I can't
stress that you know tag manager is
there to help you track interactivity on
the site because if you have a site
that's interactive that has a video that
has a download button let's just say you
know you have all sorts of newsletter
signups Facebook YouTube buttons on your
website just like this site website does
and you want to be able to track how
many people click on that particular
button well you're gonna need tag
manager and when you have tag manager
you're gonna be able to track all of
these button clicks and interactivity on
your website without tag manager it's
gonna be hard to do that so that's an
introduction to tag manager if you guys
have any comments or questions as you
may this some of you this may be new to
you go ahead and put a comment or go
ahead and add a question to the comment
section right below this video and we'll
be sure to answer it and so stay tuned
we're gonna have more webinars on tag
manager as we move along so thank you
again for joining if you need more
information please visit simply learn
comm or again add a comment or question
to the comment section below this video
thank you again and I'll see you soon
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learn YouTube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos to nerd up and get certified
click here